[Musique]
voilà moi ça m'en fous je suis désolé il
y a tous les détenus qui ont fait des
choses beaucoup moins graves ils sont
tous ensemble et lui il est tranquille
il peut se balader tout seul ça m'en
fous justement la question
comprenez-vous que Marc du tout soit
isolé du reste des prisonniers on en est
déjà parlé de ce genre de truc et Gilles
Verdez vous dites oui alors je précise
que je comprends son isolement parce que
c'est un isolement particulier c'est
l'une de 9 mètres carrés droite visite
limitée il n'a pas le droit au téléphone
son courrier je pense pas non je crois
pas il est extrêmement limité il est
coupé du monde extérieur donc cet
isolement là avec toutes ces demandes
remises en liberté rejetées
les demandes de mise en liberté sont
rejetées
donc cet isolement là qui est un
isolement
strict dur ça ça me va bien voilà que
plus personne n'est contact avec lui
c'est ce que je voudrais moi
personnellement pardon mais j'arrive pas
à avoir de la peine pour ces mecs là on
parle séquestrer violet tuer des mineurs
moi je m'en fous qui se fasse insulter
je m'en fous qu'il se fasse tabasser
c'est c'est c'est c'est honteux et
pourquoi les prisonniers sont en colère
parce que il y en a pas toute la vidéo
il fait des bras d'honneur voilà alors
le fait qu'il soit isolé de fête et de
deux ils font référence dans la dans la
vidéo au fait qu'il va qui demande à
sortir et rien que ça c'est vrai que le
mec qui demande à sortir mais ferme ta
gueule ce mecan n'a rien fait alors dans
la société pour demander ça mais pas le
saladier non de demander ça il a rien à
bien sûr toute seule et voilà c'est tout
il s'appelle Marc Dutroux et qui reste
au trou point barre
[Rires]
je vous demande je vous demande de
penser à moi je suis à côté d'une
grenade dégoupillée
ça peut péter d'un moment alors d'accord
c'est incroyable vraiment
on reviendra sur toi moi je suis
d'accord avec ce que Raymond aller dire
enfin
non c'est vrai qui crève dans sa prison
et on s'en fiche totalement de ces
considérations et voilà il y a même pas
de discussions à avoir sur ce sujet là
et qui se fasse insulter va encore
heureux et voilà après qui réponde à
faisait des petites bras d'honneur comme
ça enfin voyons ça Bernard toi tu
comprends bah évidemment que je
comprends c'est un type ignoble il
devrait même pas qu'il soit isolés des
autres prisonniers mais évidemment
d'abord c'est pour sa survie à lui quoi
qu'il en soit et est-ce qu'on je
comprends je comprends que je sois isolé
tant mieux d'ailleurs
on est des hommes quand même pas ouais
on est quand même un peu intéressant
non
en fait pardonnez-moi mais il faudrait
demander aussi aux parents des victimes
en fait est-ce qu'ils ont envie qu'ils
se fasse tuer par exemple dans la prison
est-ce qu'ils ont pas envie peut-être
que Mario trou passe le restant séjour
en prison parce qu'ils ont pas envie de
voir des images de Marc Dutronc
il se balade pas il est à l'isolement il
a le droit à un tour dans 5 minutes les
enfants ils ont pas le droit des tours
et je peux dire que les parents là ils
ont pas envie de faire des tours moi je
sais pas pourquoi ces gens-là auraient
des privilèges en fait qu'ils assument
les actes qu'ils ont fait et je les
mettrai avec les autres d'études si ça
se passe bien buté
mais ce serait peut-être pas mal hein je
peux juste finir si ça se passe bien
tant mieux pour lui ça se passe bien il
fait ça détention comme les autres si ça
se passe mal les surveillants viennent
essayent de défendre et il fait sa
détention comme les autres je ne veux
pas de privilège je ne veux pas qu'on le
voit comme ça à la télé je ne veux pas
qu'il passe là parce que lui parce vous
vous votre justice à vous c'est de
mettre un mec comme ça dans 9 mètres
carrés comme Gilles la rappeler sans
rien du tout sans sans aucun truc
pendant 60 70 ans est-ce que vous vous
croyez que vous êtes plus humain que les
propos que j'ai moi parfois en laissant
en mettre comme ça qui est en train de
devenir dingue à juste titre et ça me
dérange pas s'il devient dingue mais ce
que vous vous sentez plus humain en
laissant un mec 70 ans faire les 100 pas
comme ça dans une prison oui tous les
mecs qui ont été en qhf tous les mecs
qui ont été dans les quartiers de
sécurité ils vous disent il y a rien de
pire que les que les quartiers de haute
sécurité
à moi moi je préfère qu'il disparaissent
plutôt qui marche comme ça
ça m'intéresse pas de le voir marcher
pendant 70 ans après on va j'ai eu des
tweets on m'a dit tu es pas humain tu
veux tuer les gens je veux pas tuer les
gens je veux juste que les violeurs
d'enfants comme ça à faire des bras
d'honneur et je rejoins ce que dit Cyril
je veux même pas que la famille et les
proches le voit en fait il a même pas il
a même pas existé donc voilà juste ça
moi
en Allemagne il y a ça regardez aux
États-Unis
si vous voulez si vous voulez moi je
vous dis aux États-Unis il y a la peine
de mort je dis pas vous là je suis pas
en train de vous dire la peine de mort
pour tout le monde je suis en train de
vous dire est-ce que vous pensez vous
humains est-ce que vous pensez plus
humain quand vous laissez un mec marcher
dans une cour comme ça pendant 70 ans
est-ce que vous pensez plus humain non
mais c'est une bonne question alors moi
je comprends tout à fait Raymond en
revanche je préfère je préfère comme ça
qui souffrent jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours comme un con dans une cellule de 9
mètres carrés ça c'est une vraie
souffrance parce que si tu là-bas ou
s'il a des problèmes là et là il souffre
le mec il est tout seul il est isolé par
la personne et c'est bien fait pour ta
gueule
qui sortira jamais
elle dit si tu là-bas que ça fait du
bien à la famille mais sauf que ça
résout jamais les problèmes et que un
enfant l'enfant est décédé ça ne
ressuscitera pas malheureusement pour
les familles et la plupart des
documentaires que tu vois quand les
familles
reviennent après les exécutions aux
États-Unis elle dit ça n'apaise ça
n'apaise pas je pensais que ça me ferait
du bien et finalement ça ne m'a pas fait
le bien que je pensais que ça me ferait
donc voilà moi évidemment que je préfère
que ce mec soit en prison pendant 70 ans
éloigné de tous et que et que par
ailleurs on enlève des soucis
supplémentaires au gardien de prison qui
déjà ne savent plus comment faire et
sont débordés plutôt que de devoir avoir
à gérer en plus les altercations avec ce
type là tu sais pas combien
de prison il coûte lui il se trouve il
coûte des gens lui ça se trouve faut
trois quatre personnes pour les balades
pour le balader ouvrir les portes sans
qu'il croise personne qui te tu crois
qu'il rentre tout seul dans sa cellule
il coûte de l'argent à toi il a pas de
ça
extrêmement choquant et là je rejoins ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure Cyril
c'est ces demandes en liberté ça les
demandes en liberté c'est vraiment la
honte et depuis 2013 il peut
effectivement demander heureusement
c'est rejeté qu'est-ce qui a créé une
immense mais heureusement que c'est
rejeté en revanche en revanche qui a
créé une immense polémique c'est que
vous vous souvenez de s'accomplisse
Michel Martin parce qu'il n'était pas
seul du coup il y avait Michel Martin
elle elle a été condamnée lourdement et
bien elle a été placée sous bracelet
électronique dès 2011 est libéré en 2022
et ça en Belgique ça a créé un scandale
et c'est pour ça que lui réitère c'est
demande et que les avocats disent
puisqu'elle a eu la demande
comme ça peut être libéré
tous les soirs on dit ça c'est honteux
ça c'est un scandale ça ceci ça cela
n'en fait rien pour changer les choses à
chaque fois moi j'aimerais dire quelque
chose
les crapuls les plus grosses crapules
ceux qui ceux qui font des crimes
ignobles ceux-là là faut leur dire un
jour qui a plus de il y a plus les
règles du jeu elles ont changé si tu
fais ça il y a pas de billard retour
il y en a peut-être dans le lot il y en
a peut-être sur 10 il y en a peut-être
trois qui vont se dire non non il y a
pas de billard autour et peut-être qu'on
aura sauvé des gens je suis peut-être
dans l'utopie je suis pas dans le monde
oui oui mais moi c'est mon monde à moi
parce que malheureusement
malheureusement les chiffres dans les
états où il y a la peine de mort ça ne
résout pas les problèmes et que et qu'on
voit qu'il y a encore des pédophiles et
qui a encore des meurtriers qui est
encore et donc ça n'a rien à dire que
nous ne sommes pas au tribunal ok mais
une personne comme ça qui a enlevé la
vie aux enfants qui avaient des choses
qui sont inadmissibles qui sont
dégueulées cette personne ne devrait
normalement ne pas avoir le droit de se
promener en short avec des baskets
coucou super je fais mon jogging non
parce que aux États-Unis quand on fait
quand on touche aux enfants quand on est
pédophiles vous n'avez pas le droit de
sortir ainsi c'est interdit c'est un
laxisme qui est en Belgique
et justement on en parle encore
d'histoire du téléphone donc elle est
téléphone en prison et encore sur TiK
ToK on lui donne de la cette personne
alors qu'ils devraient rester
d'autres détenus cette personne ne
devrait pas avoir le droit de se
dégourdir les gambettes parce que les
autres sont morts point barre
quand même hypocrite au nom de quoi
l'isolement pourquoi on se met toujours
du côté des pédophiles pourquoi on veut
protéger les pédophiles ou non
tu as fait quelque chose d'atroces de
monstrueux va avec les autres détenus il
y a pas que les pédophiles qui se font
tabassés énormément d'argent en plus en
danger c'est pas pourquoi l'isolement et
pourquoi les demandes de remise en
liberté qu'est-ce que ce mec là doit
faire et veut faire dans la société
ils vont dire oui vous avez vu ils ont
dit il faut les mettre avec les autres
détenus ils sont pas humains et ont
comme parce qu'aujourd'hui et moi je
repars moi je reparle de l'affaire Lola
qui nous a tous Voilà dévasté et ben
voilà donc on nous a reproché d'avoir
dit qu'il fallait une justice rapide
voilà on voulait approchez rapide et
tout le monde reste devenu à chaque fois
il parle de débordement voilà je vous
dis oui on veut oui on va procès rapide
une justice rapide sur le cas qu'on n'en
sait pas sur les cas on n'est pas au
courant on veut une enquête longue si ça
doit durer de 5 ans sinon j'ai la
faillite on sait que c'est elle on sait
qu'il y a des témoins il y a tout le
monde a parlé son chauffeur VTC son pote
sont bien sûr les preuves ont après
compact on continue
bien sûr
aujourd'hui elle est dans la sauce donc
si tu veux
les parents les parents ils en ont marre
ils ont envie que ça évite tu sais quand
ils vont se retrouver au tribunal dans
un an je vais essayer de tribunal parce
qu'ils disent au bout de 3 ans 4 ans et
enfin soulagé on va pouvoir
les mêmes exactement au bout de 9 ans
ils ont on sort de 4 ans de souffrance
non non 4 ans il faut aller à peine
qu'on te rappelle après
on dit des choses qui dérangent un petit
peu parce que vous savez mais ça fait ça
bouscule les les bien-pensants qui sont
tranquilles chez eux et qui donne des
leçons donc ça c'est insupportable mais
bon sur Marc Dutroux ce que dit
Guillaume je suis sûr que ça va être
repris parce que voilà tu dis un truc
voilà tu dis pour toi il doit être avec
les autres détenus évidemment et si il
se passe un drame pour toi il se passe
un drame évidemment de payer pour ce
qu'il a fait parce que sinon
en faisant peur ah c'est crapule et en
leur disant il y aura pas de billets
autour plutôt que de dire je vais en
garder un 35 ans 50 ans en prison parce
que peut-être qu'un jour il va m'envoyer
un texto en disant bien il faut que je
te parle je veux pas mais non je suis
pas naïf pas que du tronche il va pas
violer une petite fille je suis moins
naïf que de me dire dans une prison si
le bagne sans sortir sans rien faire ça
m'intéresse pas m'intéresse pas de voir
comme ça ça m'intéresse pas de le voir
comme ça il faut faire juste il a parlé
20 alors regardez il y a des gens qui
disent qu'il réagissent encore sur les
réseaux des téléspectateurs qui regardez
la meurtrière de Lola elle est
tranquille dans une cellule avec la télé
comment tu peux pas devenir fou après la
petite est sous terre et elle elle vit
c'est inadmissible et n'oubliez pas de
faire ça arrêtez
voilà et après ils vont faire des
randonnées en forêt sans protection ils
vont finir par sortir et s'il reste il y
a 20 % de récidive chez les pédophiles
c'est 20% de trop c'est mes classes qui
crèvent en prison encore une fois
43% et non à 56% voilà ils sont c'est
serrés voilà c'est ça